on va en avant d'une hécatombe si rien
n'est fait si l'État ne prend pas en
charge l'explosion des coûts de
l'énergie on tira tous le rideau c'est
pour ça qu'on a mis en place la journée
de deuil alors est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer aujourd'hui pourquoi le
prix d'énergie sans doute tous mais
pourquoi aujourd'hui c'est invivable
pour vous qu'est-ce que c'est à la fin
du mois vous pouvez pas vous en sortir
alors faut savoir déjà je vais planter
le décor avant que Julien arrive moi je
suis artisan boulanger on est un mot et
j'ai lancé un groupement d'artisan
boulanger qui s'appelle grain de blé on
se réunit entre artisan boulanger pour
mieux négocier nos tarifs d'accord y
compris les tarifs de l'énergie d'accord
en ce moment je ne fais que ça bien sûr
partez du principe il y a un artisan
boulanger en moyenne consomme 2000 euros
par mois d'électricité si son tarif est
multiplié par 10 il met la clé sous la
porte c'est impossible de c'est
impossible de tenir et c'est ça 2000
euros d'électricité en moyenne par mois
donc 2000 euros s'acceptable en revanche
du jour au lendemain vous passez à 20000
euros par mois possible
et en plus de ça là c'est vraiment le
cas en ce moment c'est vraiment le cas
alors
fin fin décembre ça sera vraiment le cas
pour 80% là vous êtes à combien là pour
l'instant moi j'ai la chance d'avoir un
tarif bloqué jusqu'à mai 2023 d'accord
je paye 1500 euros par mois mais là vous
vous battez pour les autres
je prêche pour tous les autres
finalement pourquoi qu'est-ce qui va se
passer là ça va ça va fermer les
boulangers vont fermer une par une une
par une en fait ce qui se passe c'est
que l'État a mis en place plusieurs
aides dans un premier temps il y a une
aide pour les 36 KBA en gros les tarifs
bleus nous on n'y a pas le droit on
consomme trop ensuite il y a eu des des
aides pour les entreprises énergivores
encore une fois on n'y a pas le droit
par contre faut pas oublier que pendant
le covid on était les seuls ouverts bien
sûr on est les le commerce préféré des
Français et pour autant on est c'est
pour compte donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait si
on regarde du côté de la Belgique ils
sont tous en train de fermer un par un à
partir de janvier 2023 ça sera la même
chose donc faudra prendre l'habitude
d'aller chercher son pain dans les
grandes surfaces c'est incroyable non
mais c'est fou ce que vous dites et
c'est réel je vous lis c'est pas à
échéance non il parle pas dans 2 4 6 ans
il parle là dans deux mois dans trois
mois là là
le début 2023 et là de plus en plus il y
en a qui mettent l'accinateur ils
peuvent pas s'en sortir pourquoi
aujourd'hui ils sont passés quoi de 2000
à 10000 déjà bah la plupart là Julien il
a vu sa facture multiplier par 4 et si
avec l'électricité le problème c'est que
tout augmente la matière première la
farine le sucre le beurre tout tout vous
avez augmenté les prix on a augmenté les
prix mais au bout d'un moment faut se
rendre compte que le consommateur final
c'est les clients vont pas pouvoir payer
leurs baguettes c'est impossible surtout
quand on voit que dans les grandes
surfaces au contraire il casse les prix
ça sera donc là c'est un problème
insoluble exactement c'est pour ça que
le mouvement est sans étiquette et que
ce soit
tout le monde essaye de récupérer tout
donc un moment exactement c'est pour ça
que j'insiste bien là j'ai commencé ils
ont essayé déjà de vous récupérer
comme d'habitude finalement c'est ça
c'est toujours le c'est toujours le cas
non aujourd'hui je voulais que vous
soyez là sur le plateau j'ai rien dit
parce que
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour vous
c'est pas seulement un témoignage voilà
et après on va passer à autre chose
j'aimerais savoir nous notre petite
échelle et tous les gens qui nous
regardent qui sont directes à 20h39 TPMP
moi je vous jure que ça me ça me fait
une peine folle de voir énormément de
boulanger qui me disent c'est terminé
Cyril j'ai des centaines de messages
c'est terminé pour moi dans un mois
c'est fini il y en a qui me disent c'est
déjà fini de l'accord de coût finalement
j'ai l'impression que tant qu'il y aura
pas un boulanger qui se sera suicidé
l'étain ne bougera pas c'est horrible
mais voilà malheureusement avec les
autorités avec alors moi je suis en
contact avec la ministère exactement
c'est la ministre de nutrition alors on
essaye vraiment de forcer au maximum là
ce soir il y a Emmanuel Macron qui doit
prendre la parole pour annoncer des
aides mais encore une fois est-ce qu'on
va rentrer dans les clous c'est quoi les
aides qui vous faudrait pour que les
boulangeries voilà puissent subsister je
peux organiser ici je peux lui demander
peut-être avec à la ministre de
l'Industrie donc Agnès était une
rencontre trop vous et des et et la
ministre pour que on puisse avancer sur
des choses ou même en dehors de
l'émission vous pouvez la voir ce qu'on
peut faire c'est quelqu'un qui est voilà
très ouvert qui a envie de discuter qui
qui est prête à discuter je vous dis sur
différentes choses mais il faut qu'elle
sache les problèmes parce que je veux
dire moi je me suis rendu compte d'une
chose aussi c'est que parfois
ils sont pas au courant les problèmes il
y a beaucoup je vous dis même de
personnes nage politique et qui
apprennent parfois des problèmes en
regardant l'émission je vous jure que
c'est vrai qu'il me disent bon ça on
savait pas on savait pas on va on peut
aider comment on peut faire pour avancer
là-dessus je peux pas croire aujourd'hui
les responsables politiques se disent en
France dans quelques mois les
boulangeries je vous dis le nombre de
boulangeries peut être divisé par entre
5 et 10 c'est ça ça peut être voilà on
est 32000 boulangers en France
exactement donc il peut en rester voilà
je vous le dis il peut rester 3000 dans
dans quelques mois exactement ça va
tomber les une après les autres il a
très bien expliqué quand vous avez 2000
euros par mois d'électricité que vous
passez pour l'instant à 10000 et que
vous allez passer vous le savez dans
quelques mois à 20000 impossible de vous
en sortir comment on fait on va pas
vendre la baguette
c'est n'importe quoi voilà donc parce
que forcément les les personnes aussi
tout le monde on le voit on le voit ici
tout le monde là en ce moment tout
augmente et on voit les gens ne s'en
sortent pas les gens s'en sortent plus
donc en fait c'est c'est après on va
dire bah les boulangers c'est fini on
peut plus acheter du pain parce que
c'est trop cher et derrière comme on l'a
dit les grandes surfaces elle casse tes
prix les boulangeries et c'est vrai que
c'est c'est compliqué alors vous avez
lancé donc ce mouvement grain de blé
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
alors eh ben qu'on soit entendu et qu'on
puisse bénéficier au juste à juste titre
des mêmes conditions que les PME qui ont
un bouclier tarifaire aujourd'hui ceux
qui ont le tarif bleu il bénéficie d'un
bouclier tarifaires à hauteur de 15%.
pourquoi pas élargir le spectre sur les
tarifs jaunes tout simplement comme ça
on pourrait en bénéficier
on leur reproche en fait entre
guillemets de trop consommer d'énergie
exactement donc comme les fours sont
trop puissants ils sont trop ils sont
hors bouclés
c'est pour fabriquer du pain des gâteaux
donc ils peuvent plus fonctionner c'est
une histoire de fou et des boulangeries
ne bénéficient pas du bouclier taritaire
car elles sont très énergivants il
existe bien le bouclier est arrivé la
fiche qui imite à 15 % la hausse des
prix de l'énergie pour les petites
entreprises mais il faut répondre à
trois critères un chiffre un chiffre
d'affaires inférieur à 2 millions
d'euros par an employé moins de 10
salariés avoir un compteur électrique de
moins de 36 kg volts en Volt Ampère
c'est-à-dire avoir une consommation
électrique limitée et c'est cette
dernière condition en fait qui pose
énormément de problèmes qu'au car oui
boulangerie sur 10 ne remplissent pas ce
critère c'est ce critère en fait avant
tout qu'il faut changer c'est celui-là
qui pose énormément problème on est
d'accord c'est ça donc c'est cette
condition là qu'il faut absolument
revoir sinon les boulangeries ça va
tomber et on aura plus de boulanger il y
aurait une bonne nouvelle quand même
Cyril
viendrait d'annoncer que des mesures
pour vous les boulangers pour amortir le
choc il vient de citer parmi la liste
des gens qui à qui l'élargiraient son
aide les boulangeries et ce serait
finalisé donc vendredi il vient
d'annoncer à l'instant donc très bien
avoir encore une fois si on rentre dans
les cases dans les cases
la disparition des boulangeries ça fait
partie de notre patrimoine
on est considéré comme Jérémy aussi les
boulangers vas-y Jérémy vas-y mon chéri
t'inquiète pas bah je sais que tu
arrives du train tout ça tu étais au
bout de ta vie vas-y mon chéri bon alors
toi aussi toi tu es à mou aussi
par un mot tout de suite
tu vois comme ça ça c'est réglé non non
mais toi c'est ce que nous expliquer il
y a un instant je suis pas là Julien
Jérémy c'est pareil pour toi
merci
[Rires]
Julien merci d'avoir été là non non mais
je les avais du licencier ouais c'est ça
ouais c'est ça forcément j'avais une
vendeuse et du coup une vendeuse et le
coup était vendeuse il a même pas pu
garder une vendeuse
honnêtement c'est la mort de l'artisanat
français aujourd'hui votre facture
moi par 3 là
quoi à peu près 2000 à 6000
non moi je suis passé à 1200 euros bon
après moi je suis une petite d'accord
vous avez fait votre business plan c'est
400 euros par mois
électricité je m'en sors quand on dit de
1200 comment tu fais qu'est-ce qu'il
vous reste à la fin du mois rien du tout
vous bossez vous levez à quelle heure
trois heures trois heures du matin vous
bossez jusqu'à quelle heure
je peux pas croire et je pense qu'il y a
des bonnes nouvelles je un moment un
moment je vous dis tout entendre et le
gouvernement quoi qu'il arrive à faire
la quelque chose là-dessus ça j'en suis
sûr et certain c'est rapidement qu'il
faut faire quelque chose je sais c'est
là
exactement
parce que une fois que c'est fini c'est
fini voilà exactement donc voilà si des
gens du gouvernement nous écoutent
peut-être madame la ministre en espagnol
en plus qui voilà qui veut faire bouger
les choses il faut faire bouger les
choses là dans le mois de septembre
c'est tout de suite et ben on va on va
essayer en tout cas on va voir ce que va
dire le président et on va voir dans les
prochains jours s'il y a des mesures qui
vous conviennent et qui vous permettent
de reprendre une activité normale et de
pouvoir gagner je dis pas en plus de de
gagner des des sommes incroyable au
moins de pouvoir vivre
exactement on va suivre ça et si voilà
on essaiera aussi peut-être voir si si
on peut pas organiser peut-être un
voilà une rencontre mais je pense que si
le président Macron est sur le dossier
je pense que ça va bouger assez vite je
vous dis les boulangeries ça fait partie
du patrimoine français je pense qu'on
peut ils pourront pas vous laisser
tomber je pense qu'ils vous laisseront
pas tomber vous me tiendrez au courant
très bien et vous nous tiendrez au
courant très vite mais je peux pas
croire ça et je pense que ça va bouger
très vite on va se pencher là-dessus on
vous donnera des nouvelles d'ailleurs
dès demain pour voir si ça bouge mais on
vous dira quand surtout parce que c'est
vrai que vous avez dit il y a une énorme
urgence complètement merci d'être venu
quand même c'était court et voilà mais
c'est toujours pour moi
et merci en tout cas si vous votre
boulangerie qu'on fasse un peu de pub en
Lorraine
et vous c'est quoi et nous c'est le
croissant la Viennoise fait maison à
viennoiserie exactement
on arrive dans l'hiver c'est bon j'adore
ouais
très bien en tout cas j'espère que ça va
bouger pour vous parce que voilà quand
on vous voit on n'a pas envie que que
c'est vous vous donnez combien de mois
vous avant de avec la comptable on a
regardé six mois grand maximum
et tous les boulangers sont dans ce cas
j'embrasse d'ailleurs tous les
boulangers qui nous regardent qui
travaillent comme des fous c'est un
bonheur d'aller à la boulangerie c'est
un kiffe c'est vraiment pour nous tous
c'est un kiffe de la boulangerie quand
tu dis je vais à la boulangerie tu fais
un kiff déjà sans rigoler c'est vrai tu
vois je me rappelle j'étais plus à la
boulangerie qu'à l'école je te jure que
c'est vrai j'étais plus à la boulangerie
qu'à l'école aller à la boulangerie
c'est un kiff tu vas pas nous enlever
ils vont nous enlever tous les Kiss ça
veut dire qu'il te reste 0 kiff c'est un
truc de fou et moi ce que je comprends
pas alors il y a une très bonne phrase
de Béatrice surtout pour les enfants ah
c'est vrai voilà non mais c'est vrai
merci vous voulez rajouter quelque chose
je comprends pas pourquoi l'État est
prône de partout le patrimoine français
l'artisanat et tout et que derrière on
nous enfonce mais vraiment à coup de
massue quoi c'est là non mais j'espère
qu'ils vont faire quelque chose très
très très vite rapidement je vais vous
dire voilà à partir alors des mesures
sont annoncées j'ai mais il faut qu'on
rentre aussi
Roland Lescure qu'on aime bien en plus
qui est très sympa on va essayer de
l'inviter qui était à la com avant qui
est un bon gars et voilà on me dit ça et
on me dit des mesures seront annoncées
ça va bouger pour vous très vite c'est
ce qu'on me dit en direct là vendredi
responsable politique me dit que ça va
bouger très vite pour vous sachez-le et
que Roland Lescure va apparemment
prendre le dossier en main et le
président Macron et dessus je vous le
dis il pourra pas vous laisser comme ça
là-dessus on le sait il vous savez il a
un cœur comme nous il s'est quand même
il sait comment ça se passe votre il est
tellement simple on comprend tellement
vite le truc que c'est impossible
exactement donc voilà bah merci merci en
tout cas d'avoir en tout cas